je suis très choqué sur la forme nous
venons de poser des questions au
gouvernement sur la gestion de la crise
les petits commerces bien évidemment
mais aussi la gestion de la vaccination
à venir etc
pas de réponse ou très peu de réponses
manifestement prêt ministre veut d'abord
s'adresser à la presse plutôt qu'au
parlement je trouve ça très choquant
vire il savait parfaitement qu'il y
aurait une séance de questions
d'actualité
il n'a pas dit un mot pendant une heure
et quart je ne trouve pas ça très
respectueux de ce que nous représentons
et sur le fond et bien on espère de
bonnes nouvelles
néanmoins je pense qu'il faut s'attendre
aujourd'hui sinon un durcissement en
tout cas un maintien du confinement tel
qu'il est sur les petits commerces il
faut aller réouvrir je pense qu'il
n'aurait pas fallu les fermer tout
simplement il y aurait une fallait être
équitable nous avons fait des
propositions sénat nous avons voté un
amendement d'ailleurs proposé par la
droite sénatoriale
nous l'avons soutenu qui a été balayé
d'un revers de main par le gouvernement
je pense qu'il faut faire confiance aux
territoires et notamment aux préfets et
aux sous-préfets qui aurait pu
territoire par territoire
imaginer des solutions adaptées le mot
d'ailleurs de territoire a totalement
disparu de la bouche du premier ministre
qui pourtant sont été fait le gloire
iodé le glorieux défenseur pendant de
nombreuses semaines